this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
the Thursday november 8 2012 session in
our series about green technologies and
transportation this series is produced
by the u.s. Asia Technology Management
Center which is a research center in
Stanford School of Engineering and the
first thing I want to do is to thank the
Allen minor foundation for series
sponsorship for providing financial
support that helps us we'll have some
refreshments outside afterward and you
know it's thanks to our sponsor that we
have that I also want to say a special
thanks today to Nixon Peabody which is a
law office a major law firm for
especially helping us to arrange this
session today our speaker is coming all
the way from Wuhan China and Nixon
Peabody was my first introduction to mr.
pink and I'd like to recognize mr.
Joseph Bach who is with Nixon Peabody
and hope you can say hi to Joseph who
has done a lot of great us-china work in
regard to this kind of corporate issues
so today we're going to talk about
marine transportation and marine
transportation is actually missed a lot
when people are thinking about
greenhouse gases and global warming but
right now probably from air
transportation and also marine
transportation almost four percent of
all of the carbon dioxide emissions in
the world is coming from that source
however if they don't do something about
it this percentage is predicted to
increase to like seventy two percent by
the year twenty thirty just because it's
being cut back so up many other places
and also there's an awful lot more
transport than there used to be so I've
got a few slides to sort of introduce
this whole issue
the real issue when it comes to marine
transportation is bunker oil and almost
all commercial ships are using marine
diesel engines these are very different
kinds of engines than you find in an
automobile or in a big truck they are
made to use this kind of oil that's
called bunker oil and bunker oil is a
high sulfur product of the crude oil
refining process basically you always
get it when you're trying to make
gasoline and so on and so forth so it
will be produced no matter whether it's
used or not but it has a very high
sulfur content compared to other kinds
of oil is average according to the
International Maritime Organization is
for bunker oil to have two point seven
percent sulphur by weight in the fuel
that equals about 27,000 parts per
million the diesel fuel that you use in
a car has about 50 parts per million so
50 vs 27,000 is a pretty big difference
in terms of how much sulfur there is um
so one thing about it is since its
produced and it comes out and kind of
large quantities from the refining
process it's cheap and it's very
important to the whole kind of
transportation of goods and services
across the world that shipping costs are
low and one major reason that we've been
able to preserve low shipping costs is
that these big engines use bunker fuel
but it is a source of four kinds of air
pollution sulfur dioxide or sulfur oxide
oxide plural nitrogen oxides plural also
particulate matter which is another word
for suit and thus it also contains some
sulfur in it and so forth but when you
really are smelling diesel fuel
somewhere it's the suit that tends to be
the source of
to the smell the other kind of thing is
it does produce co2 so it's a source of
four major types of air pollution just
in regard to sulfur itself sulfur oxides
the European Union which has been pretty
active in this and as you can imagine
look at the sulfur oxide emissions from
the 25 European nations in the EU total
and that's dropping like a rock
meanwhile this steady rise in sulfur
oxide emissions from ships is eventually
going to pass the emissions from
land-based all across the European Union
somewhere around twenty fifteen or
twenty sixteen they've got a similar
graph for nitrogen oxides too so this is
an issue so this means that the United
Nations got involved it is something
that you can't deal with from the laws
of any one country and the UN first
passed the International Convention for
the Prevention of pollution from ships
in 1973 and that was revised in 1978 and
the laws that people most care about are
the mark hall and x6 which first was
adopted in 97 and it took them until it
took them eight years to really bring it
into force so the Marple annex limits
that main air pollutants from ships it
also prohibits deliberate emissions of
ozone-depleting compounds regulates
shipboard incineration you can't just
burn things on ships and it also
regulates the emission of volatile
organic compounds from tankers so what's
happened in this whole world is that in
2008 they got together again and decided
they needed a much more stringent set of
protocols so the new Marple annex that
has really just started going into
effect from
2010 has stepped down targets that you
may not exceed and be in compliance with
your air pollutions so with regard to
sulfur which is one of the biggest
things here
the current state of the art was four
point five percent sulphur by weight as
a percentage of the emissions coming out
of oven of a ship from the beginning of
this year they're supposed to be at
three point five percent and the target
by 2020 is 0.5 percent that's a pretty
massive reduction in sulfur there's a
big distinction here they have what are
called emission control areas and
emission control areas are the areas
that are susceptible to the most damage
from marine-based air pollution the
entire Baltic Sea most of the North Sea
a lot of the coastal waters around the
United States are in these emissions
control areas so in the emissions
control areas it's even more severe this
means that you have to either run on a
separate set of engines or take really
different kinds of approaches to
reducing the amount of emissions oh this
was a concern by the people who put
together this set of protocols because
at the time they were thinking it could
only be handled through better quality
fuel and so there is a provision that if
they don't have enough fuel to run the
protocols as it is they will delay the
introduction of the step down so there
is a similar set of regulations for
nitrogen oxides today we're primarily
going to be talking about sulfur oxides
because that's actually the key to the
problem oh you can solve this problem in
several ways our presentation today is
about seawater scrubbing of the
emissions from these big marine diesel
engines another alternative would be to
use lower sulfur fuel but the only way
you can get lower sulfur fuel is through
greater refining and that has an energy
it also creates its own kind of sets of
environmental problems to reduce remove
sulfur from crude oil and finally you're
going to get this bunker fuel type stuff
anyway what are you going to do with it
there's even been proposals to take it
and put it back in old depleted oil
wells but they're not sure what would
happen over the lifetime of the other
thing so another option is to use some
sort of an onshore desulphurization
technique for the emissions themselves
in coal-fired power plants this is where
you get most of this stuff right now
what they have that's an alternative to
seawater is to essentially use limestone
or chalk and the chemical reaction is
going to yield gypsum which is uh what
calcium sulfate and also co2 but you
know especially on a ship you're going
to have to transport the limestone and
gypsum around which is weight that
you're paying energy costs for and the
energy costs of mining the limestone and
gypsum has got to be figured into it and
in contrast seawater is a great source
of calcium carbonate so it's what
happens in seawater is a fascinating
thing sulfur in seawater the sea is
actually the natural source of most of
the sulfur in the world and when you
have sulfur that runs off of the land
into the ocean microorganisms methylate
it and create these dimethyl sulfide and
some of those evaporate back into the
clouds and actually helped form the
seeds for clouds so dimethyl sulfate is
not necessarily a bad thing it's really
cloud seeding a lot of the sulfur stays
in the organism and so is the organism
dies in decays this is why we have lots
of sulfur in oil now right the thing
about
burning sulfur in the middle of fossil
fuels is that it emits sulfur in the
form of sulfur oxide and the sulfur
oxides almost of them all of them really
come from what people burn the only
naturally abundant place where you find
them as close to volcanic eruptions oh
and these are the things that in the
middle of the air form of sulfuric acid
and give you acid rain and also it will
combine with ammonium and create haze
which of course traps a lot of sunlight
and gives you even better global warming
so you know in the air you really don't
want these things but the natural carbon
calcium carbonate in seawater takes
these things and yields gypsum and also
co2 in the seawater seawater is a great
place to leave your co2 you can
sequester an awful lot of carbon dioxide
in the ocean so that's not an issue and
they've already found that sulfur from
seawater scrubbing barely increases even
the local readings of sulfur there's so
much sulfur in the ocean already that a
little bit more is not going to make
much difference even in a an enclosed
harbor with locks is what the source
said that I read so you know this is a
much better kind of approach today we
have a very interesting technology a
great speaker again I mentioned coming
all the way from Wuhan China mr. SG ping
invented a natural seawater scrubbing
technology for taking sulfur out of
emissions he actually comes to this from
chemical engineering background he
graduated from the wuhan university of
hydraulic and electrical engineering
back in nineteen eighty-two he's also
participated in the executive courses at
Shanghai University
he was in the expert group for
environmental protection in the
electric-powered design institute of
china's department of energy and he
founded the first chinese company that
was specialized in fossil fuel air
pollution reduction this was back in
1994 so despite all the reputation that
China has had for you know not paying
attention of this kind of thing here's a
company from 1994 that was built around
reducing air pollution in when burning
fossil fuels so he changed the name of
the company in 1997 to the China
environmental project technology company
incorporated and he first went to work
putting his technology into coal-fired
power plants so my understanding is that
now more than 40 of China's big electric
coal-fired power plants are using his
technology to scrub sulphur out of the
emissions of the power plants and in the
mid-2000s about the first time i met mr.
ping he was developing a much revised
version of this technology with the
power plant you don't worry about wait
you don't worry about size you know it's
just big is great but a much more
efficient version of this that would be
something you could put onto a ship and
he started to develop this in the
mid-2000s and in 2009 founded the
company marine protec to commercialize
this marine protec is a California
company so this is clearly a global a
global play so I'm very happy that mr.
pen can be with us today I'd like to ask
him to come up now and give us some
prepared remarks we have the chief
marketing director for C EPT mr. Jerry
Joe who's going to be the interpreter
for mr. ping and so we will have Q&A
Jerry will take care of us when it comes
to time to ask questions oh let me ask
mr. ping for your presentation thank you
so much for coming I think it's better
if you sit down and he stands baby yo
Jerry come sit down here uh well then it
is ok once you know that's why I'm so
attentive ok no wonder what so Jo can
hear density also can't I to e uma sorts
for the degree you told us anjaneri and
Joe finchy so firstly I would like to
make sense to Professor denture to make
a lot of research on this area more very
good introduction ok I can shed tears
and orange head count on Gordon tender
usually conscience without hambo the
Soho tengok daughter who coolly and also
a sense a professor than show a lot of
encouraging and the in director for many
years ago when we start our business in
a power plant mohammad Union shankardada
jolly telling you go when you are hardly
auto warranty number tassel you got
Cinderella to achieve over Wendy would
you do to repay ginger but I don't
question that you went today we just
want to share some ideas with you here
the problem a lot of people can soon as
the pollution in the atmosphere in this
year's too busy chinedu you chosen
gamble at agoura the would you believe
it 22 especially the problem is becoming
more serious this currently especially
in the two industries the energy and the
transport
treating women can deduce the Terre
Haute at times jostle your you go
zhengzhou cardin weight change whole
slew so treating jungle so 500 yoga
canova gender you change your toyota
cheater so this year we found a us sorry
currently we found that a research from
Professor James prove it from the
University of de lava is said that the
software emissions of the most largest
16 ships is equivalent to the software
emissions of all the land with a hose so
if your neck when you found the train
body would you ever go the cumbia de or
lowes chick avoid a potential so on the
convention and regulation has been
signed for 67 countries of the map whole
weekend at the time border there you go
to be hardly all the wooden number to
weld up to you the fam fam Jeep engine
toll I do you know yet you use the Holy
Father in town totally you so of all the
solutions are coming from the solutions
in the power stations in the land to
Angelica that I video question de tu
area central give us a cheer Oh yo you
guys young hardships like junker to the
warrant chichi take this woman is their
daughter leavin clarifies with a phone
find the tangent of complacency done so
as the professional attention has just
introduced there was three contenders to
solve the problem the first is using low
software furrow and using chemicals to
neutralize the acid and then it's our
solution the nature of sea water method
3 Taguchi
sabali on Tommy you got talentamerica's
ed and yvette Oh Monsieur PT de la may
la gente te te kehna hai shi de durango
fun fun Oh manjula Kaiba vs so for the
past 18 years our company cpg have
experienced a lot of research and
development development on the natural
seawater method on the use of power
stations in London for King Julien woman
touch my bottom yet all ages here also
we don't mention it they measured in to
the ship number one window can use and
it's w you just miss Ilona here on
highway she didn't know Papa issues
three qing jie jie liu so the fava so as
we are considering the by far the nest w
natural seawater squirming method is by
far the most efficiency and green
technology 3-2 win cgt dejame high is
the doc say some early to go soon the
christian soda tengo tambien tengo tumko
the child or a colleague poco take a
Genoa there you go find in the show go
omere away to God young Cara has
recibido bomba y su su division logo
cumbia de chegar do sol de durango treat
each other better so as overall the
greenhouse emissions and the cost and
the consider of the efficiency we think
natural seawater scrubbing technologists
the most the best way to in language the
requirement of marvel of the UN united
nation vertigo
nah google community intervention yet
each in center court enters into
aldehydes valley so the convention of
the United Nation has becomes those
regulations and the lower under under
laws already enforced oh we're in foster
are in the future the tone to
jean-julien you see each other to go
poof and far in the diversity Monica
young period of I saw your face and
Tarkin but regarding the employment of
the some of the regulations region year
being enforced they meet with a lot of
different difficulties some filing the
ginger sudheendra come to cheat a lock
on tom's issue on tongue go down there
you go far e non go tangent with suji
dillio D'Souza know Yolanda do you like
to tell Valley News so for the
regulation maker the people who make the
regulation they just want to have a
expectation for the refiners and the low
suffer fewer suppliers to make the
demand and speed stimulate the Fuhrer
production because the tongs hinge on a
cup 2002 DeRozan be mayor show you
telling you got sued Honda itchy but
mayo dried out holes like Kodak dealio
the center but let's say the current
state has the refiners of all over the
world they didn't get the response of
the expectation they didn't our investor
to increase the production of low sulfur
oil with a mutual gravity huge in
English muffins Allah news income you
denied return and there is still some
debate on how to implement the
convention some room the order to solve
it in da latina you go sitting just go g
to oly your own condoms your way
changing chi-su go oman she wanna go to
do to the computer vision
with just no news that the in Europe the
intern tenco is a independent
international maybe some ship owners of
the tanker they just a su e you to block
the implementation number so loopy video
content that is 0 UT da hai o legal cara
Heisman Liam Quadrophenia the UH no
funca so it except the using law suffer
a loss suffer affero as the professor
denture mentioned that we have another
two choice is using chemical method and
using seawater Messer now Matt's home in
this video telephone return that the
faith and that is happy so as to the
practice there's a very big difference
of these two method you don't do it also
osw to the show hawk hallelujah that's
the quality in advance jajaja dolly on
its ear so you can see that the inst a
blue measured will consume less energy
and resources but the chemical method
will consume a lot of materials rousset
NJ has a hot evening has the tangent
official has a socio de change will come
get to the beach rainbow lodge or
university Nevada EG do you concur the
ninja the Landrum going both in that fit
on that is high so whatever is talk
about the fresh water consumption
chemicals and the higher does the West
need to be depot disposal and additional
more storage spaces in the ship is a
very important thing for the ship they
space the occupation and also the port
the instruction of the part they also
very different
today where you goin t just town change
edit a goonie the nokri you may have
cheese red targets ahora el mozo owe me
five yet number to conquer the ninja
leaf 800 that so when we are calculate
in the data of the two method we can see
very big impact for the parts the users
or Google+ another you goonie to jump a
young lad way moda decision yahoo locum
you a number to virtual yet generation
com so just look if we using the
chemical method to reducing to reduce
emissions to comply with the UN
regulations that will be a happen like
this josue Yuri saw her powder auckland
nanka what I urge all the solution uses
shisha Tarly on the feature Rajjo
taichung or grin come join you in cali
on the country okay just assuming there
is a ship land to the auckland part then
it will our job a lot of a hundred
wrists and also to reload the chemical
and the fresh water that's the internal
hazard of ova dere important but is
totally different if we using the
nutri-seawater number the intended you
go cameron hodge way like journey
sahasra nota area how do we do you
imagine sumit inshallah sabali and eva
you just for us to use a natural
seawater subscribing the suffers in
emissions we have experienced for over
18 years from Joseon Carson Sega woman
card Kaiba Emma change your teeth heck
yeah me fat indeed oh hayoung NSW Cooney
today yoyoyo Liam tota so from 1994 we
start to develop with the
NSW Messer and came into implementation
and installed at nineteen nineteen i
surly anchored in town dosa say yo
jajaja young children whole time nama
common so chainsaw da re aaja re o
hardly older sulla Lucretia sir to
target sundown you the young bass sighs
so sighs the one to Noren so I found aha
oh so so this to a power plant are all
putting to use at about a ton a 2000
also so let me see the amount of the
emission reduction of so2 by the only 12
coal fire units above is it equivalent
to the emission of more than 230 of
300,000 tons of all your tankers number
two later pendulum would Tamara tengo
but you thought the fighting hunger then
you got one from fat Jinian like a
contagious all right get how you got a
woman woman de you gotta go to Angela
forgot I just from the early helium at
atonality so tense I'm so several years
ago when we I wanna meet with Professor
danger he just asked me how can I put
this so big equipments to be a smaller
one and install into a ship today we
just installed it in on on a ship at
2011 and today we are giving him a
result now 37 is the the sanggunian
social agenda is w the CDG so this is
the three pictures this farming
equipment for the three need to be a
squirrel scrub not redistribute is the
woman tremble acidity the drones and
honey so you can see the
the obviously a scrubber use it used in
the ship used as installed inside of the
ship in the cabin Quentin hi facilities
with the Holy thing we've had the
creative UND conoces the tangent of the
toilet encounter so this theory of how
can use a natural seawater to watch the
sulfur professor denture has already
introduced I'm 32 the Union you took a
tool like Christian journalist with me
go 20 not you sir da me oh hayoung she
did the chat I hard way jana to go loose
and sent a clue either finding you hope
career away so he the rooty the jungle
to Ohio so here we just want to explain
that before the scrubbing the sulfur the
sock so2 are we up loot the atmosphere
and the land environment and then it
will return to the oceans through the
river's number woman to reserve just
singe are you go see the dogs run to go
around Hollywood painting yo home see ya
toda hiya so for us we just add one
equipment in SW EGC to scrub this
software the socks and the change it
into the software is kind of salt and
the coming to the see the topo hula from
the new leader sintac 22 hi uncle Andy
yes you're hot so that is how we can
protect the environment of the land and
also friendly affront to the nature and
the days the ocean there to you only
number three he wrote engines unda
survey carranza omaha fishery of mentos
amo de agua mode chichi that one bother
quitting yota so it's only a theory but
we master our
combined with the requirement of IMO and
the United Nation the standard en su
nombre de ESO media really cool how they
all went our own agenda yes that so are
we have a siege hell on the ship named
the new who is all your tanker Cinnabon
example if I
Cairo
sorry oh yes the map psyllium Bogota
push it didn't have any cash 30 sold it
down well then Tamra
because some esta buena to the solution
that Key West arguing or the show so on
this are your tank are we just take
please the senator Obama dangerous a
walking penis rubbing so this is a
selling sir we put it on
number Leonardo da yo changing to a
movie on TV which ended up with you know
so as we know every car the automobile
has a silencer if we have no the sensor
if there we were a very big noise free
time go to forums video trying to change
so for the ship we also have a
challenger are after the engine there's
a time I gotta come di be hunting down
there is a Shinjo that's my goal dimelo
work again meet you with you and Ron so
they but they're not that different than
in the ship with the space is very small
so we have no more space to install our
new equipment in 20 ml serjilla you
catch in chi Chi Chi Chi Chi Chi aura
hari oh yeah you're sharing a woman that
should i had a challenge so we design
our that's the scoring system the
equipment we can install it to take
place of the senator but also having
function of the sellers
Omaha Yolanda is WGC the force and I
egos and diversity so there's also
allowed another advantages of our system
these are women's to do tada 220 pathog
the chain buddha when sheep symmetry we
are deal with the whole are exhausting
deaths of the men and Jenny amigos con
mucha woman they're all those work
another 2g least yeah yolk and RGB
curate how many bad thoughts villain
work to you givenchy either develop a
cheating so this is a difference from
several are the other impairments in
Europe because in the other system in
Europe installed in a ship adjusted can
deal with some some of the exalting guys
not the it's not a hundred percentage
it's just a somehow the auxiliary
engines and 0 part of the demand number
one no no me diga chichi does the
journey so yolan the matter don't I yada
take a qualified to go tell you you in a
John ChaCha Chinchin antigua 10 shots to
the high school so the the ship with
installed our increment have sealed in
the southeast and northeast of Asia and
sealed about 2000 hours number turn
there you go high circles on your IM 0
to do so so changa you got tongue go 20
so common so change the recording room
changing a transgender you go Jude so
gentle so it is a cc is an author esta
our department from IMO supervise that
the whole passage higher yo tengo
chained to the tree Saudi so Angela and
I am Oh your past would
we talked with Regina so of all the
designs and installations and the
manufacturing of the payments are oh are
as the according to the requirement of
the IMO npc 184 r 5 and r 9 in clemente
now Martin change the reticular hi so we
always try to talk on how the man who I
am o de Ojo so as to the taters of them
from the monitoring the results are all
very good to be in line wins the IMO
requirements to pursue a woman changing
so soda a million way and it's a tableau
me yes recently answer go come you head
up to each other you got you survive so
that is why we say that maybe the
natural seawater method it's the best
way but solution for the the employment
of the IMO and union see it again thanks
so if I can I would like to ask the
first question what kind of
certification do you have to get from
now before this becomes a commercial
product gemma doogal cleaner whatta ya
say we go Indian Ocean Shores I a woman
to hold search and social services here
on the show tonight on each year to the
sugar and john AA meeting i didn't dare
to register engine cylinder turbo honey
the crater so teens in the condo today
we are doing certifications from the
society the there is the rule of the
marine time industry you had so you
already have 2000 hours of this sea
trial that was a successful test will
you have to get another 2,000 hours or
another 10,000 hours what do you need
for the certification as a no one
machine I yo gotti I should enhance a
looming extremities outside so you go
shower
he goes me on a mission and I'm all
going to change the render in your young
girl Guido got cheated on your time
Amanda had a rotten torch okay so there
is a very streak Qaeda line from IMO
which has the 120 by the rules and do
according the requirement from imo ok
and so to be very frank to that end it
would be great to have the cooperation
of some shipping company right there's a
time at Ajanta hello Zoe that super easy
crazy HR long story sir codes 1030
easier so should i search for her so
we'll know where time goes easy daughter
who taught all core coma tubing tremble
so siendo tan Ganzer ya beaucoup is yet
sheraton hotel cool so yes we have
always cooperate with some ship owners
included the ship owners to sponsor
asleep for the sea trial and somehow
some another ship owners they just a
connector with us is there any
restriction either by the china
government or the US government about
what kind of shipping companies you can
cooperate with if you're asking them to
do a test trial which is a line integral
unit h how long / let's all make what
it's on bulletin for who is yet to be
the change tamba hali johanna suomi
muchas which is what a quad isn't too
charlie so the marine industry that for
the ship is the the most international
industry Your Honor I have Wi-Fi I I
know Zurich wizard to water than I am
owed solve all the rules and the
regulations are according to the
Department of I I'm oh ok ok excellent
so what is all for and what you should
kind of that data jumper ok so
it looked like the silencer is a
component of chips is very different
from ship to ship but they all have one
but they're all different shapes and
sizes for it pestle think the
Continental Italian see I also make a
change boo Yong time to go da da da da
da when it kind of goes on so what's
your question there how do you design
the technology to be such radically
different shapes so Tyler London this is
my eyes answers and three put on the
timesheet so they were sure it was a
technicality cause I like my dad has a
sale on eBay as well sanchi part of the
group EG radical time where the farm
ddtc or you could put in a question so
currently the there's the stable
relationship between the senator and the
engine the size the center of the engine
so it may be becoming standard if i can
add something here these standards for
the NX the lemarchal NX you notice how
they were graduated in these days and I
saw three dates and how what percentage
it was supposed to be there's a similar
kind of differences between tier 1 ships
that were built after the year 2000 tier
two ships which would be built after
2011 and tier 3 ships which would be
built you know and launched from 2020
and so the tier two and Tier three ships
that are just being built they can
actually cooperate with the engine
manufacturers and have a standard system
but the thing is you've got an awful lot
of and the the standards are going
to apply retroactively Lee to every ship
built after 1990 and so that means that
there will be a lot of semi custom work
yeah yeah yeah
okay so I'm gonna send a chemical
equation you had that you produce co2 in
gas form as a result is that something
you would be concerned about or is
asking for you so you taken care of
about it I look okay in the chemical
equation that on the slides you produce
co2 gas as one of the products is that
something that's more easily taken care
of what or that uncovered by my phone
just hundred elusive is too short to go
to go an email client is eager do ba
reloop I'm on a high on even in high
awesome see how do you see i'll call you
goin T so I 0 means the the software
into the sea the problem of chemical co
to co to za nya to tell her to give a
meal chiffon so yeah haha yes yes do
that cuando NEC the two questions in
Chaouen the more ticket Hoover saw down
the aisle seven desert to attend gory
and you tell them how they saw how to
show how the cheat Hollywood today so
number she'd had a long haha show her
Italian uncovered Sharon I would the
China defense today haha no paper I am
Peter the three has to go to hook a
hardened Python 3 TD you double so for
the problem of the environment
protection is the very integrated
problem lots of factors also we have a
in this function wave we see some co2
but by far this this measure this
compared with the other method is the
last so the other other method that law
suffer and the using chemical they are
released on even even more even more so
let me ask a very simple question yeah
Oh mr. pang your technology works
by passing the emission through seawater
right the emitted gases pass through
seawater which is basically in liquid
form
it's not steam as it turning a yes sorry
so okay he's basically droppeth is like
a shower jajaja java the glass
automobiles and doctors come from the
tub so what happens to the sea water
after it passes after the emission
passes through it I can answer all your
Hydra data is equal to finances
hononegah tragic armario fine fine
you'll be the reaction the seawater and
the emission what happened that yeah
what happens to the waste seawater yes
just as she charged it with me huh hello
very casual she saw a whole number haha
oh hi Benton do also and yen saw devil
you say yeah transitive a hydrazone
photo is hydrogen the onion ginger eaten
yet imma take you down Dargis rosana sir
hi Shane your do so i end up the
appendix the scene yo yo honey and the
ground and target drive to the you treat
high stress which is a possibility no
higher you see did atticus a cheat on
the other yet wait end up I've in the
sack no no so the one the emissions meet
with the say water same water will
absolve the suffers and then the so2
into a sulfate it's a kind of salt and
they will add so as a squirming say
water swarming seawater the percentage
of the software content will add more
only three percentage yeah and so the
seawater is is basically set out of the
ship right back to the oceans you guys
how did you miss us honey honey melon do
yes honey because I'm guessing that
since the seawater is in droplet form a
lot of the CEO to that's produced is
also suspended in the sea water itself
it's not really in the atmosphere final
thing holds the guy's a creep on Ohio
man you can put a heck of a lot of co2
and water rising intelligence question
on the high street palo highs reaching
in 10 as long as shown on what you know
yo you moving since another haha yeah
which and the hydrogen yes we both had
two Koreas are down the question yes
some of the co tools into this a but
it's very small well image into the
atmosphere we need to water you use a
car peach it I don't even offer to host
another a hot dosa so that is just a
compare of all the methods this is a the
lowest emission for co2 okay okay thank
you Jim know that co2 going into the
ocean already acidifying the ocean
making it more acid which is not a good
thing but you're putting less than
normally so that's a good thing how
about the the deal hon but he's sulfur
does that as a science been established
what is the effect of sulfur goodness
you are so how did that with the pub on
a TV show universe' too good do I
shouldn't I shouldn't have doing every
time to hide it a yarmulke back so it
ties that was a bigger deal she's all
kind of my owning it but we are there x
rated as you know it's not get this one
do means the you are worried to see what
are being more SE and also be having
more sulfur in general yeah I can answer
in a minute television so the acid times
youtube with that I think it's a
negligible from your process first I'll
notice would be the output ph and the
field trial was seven
so that's mine you know that's pretty
acid neutral oh the point about sulfur
in the seawater is that it's actually a
part of the natural processes of so many
of the organisms that live in the sea
water that it's really you know going
home and most of the sulfur that gets
into seawater is actually running off
from the land so it's natural runoff
from rivers and everything is already
putting a lot of sulfur into seawater
the increase in sulfur concentration in
the seawater is negligible I mean it's
not even measurable would you know
Colleen very locally to the ship it's
measurable right to touch it you son to
yes I make with you nothing before this
suppose of the world that mix it with
fresh seawater a little bit so it's even
nationally and all the shape is over
even before it actually i'll use the
show ok so i given that many governments
around the world or try to implement
these standards i do you think this
technology where would be subsidized so
that retro actively ships can install
this or do the ship owners have to pay
the full price of installation so for
the fatima won't you those is your
channel who a way to go so we watch imma
do mean the where the cylinders
well-paid the technology well okay so
the new protocols are requirements
uh-huh that is an alarm at you must meet
our their government programs anywhere
that would help the ship owners pay for
upgrading their ships yes to chosen for
the fact we can to help it doesn't know
she's actually don't even turn the
lights on it alright so he said so i
don't know tu mujer en women use their
own way to them just a pass to go to
file in the
did you choose your the two element is
it yo GG so currently we also have a
point that for the Environmental
Protection the Environment Program we
need it must be a economic economical as
a woman of granules user gingy de risa
so our point of view is that the
economical our technologies of green
technology in my government I hope just
go Hawk gonna be good producer because
the back of the high cost that means
high cost of energy high cost of
materials that is also are another good
way to protection can I ask a question
follow up what is the average price of
marine bunker fuel versus the average
price of diesel fuel used in a truck or
something do you know Sonya Gulati
bending a tragic be on the video da
dodje yeah you similarly you been doin a
tahoe today oh and I thought down some
pie maker you don't need to mark the
bottom so it is a fluent but yeah yes
but maybe maybe two or three hundred
tongues a dollars for Tom uh-huh for the
role near the regular terminix marine
never yes David O'Neill so two or three
hundred dollars into town versus how
much dollars per gallon or the audio
channels away you evil angel just a logo
yo yo yo yo ma tante arroyo whoa buddy
maybe he's doing so hot you come on
autodoc I mean the who you know which
are jumper in the zoo there's a ton to
material the target on the HM again as a
whole
older aharonovitch our jumper news so
there's a data from the Europe when the
the price of the oil if increased
increased the than the ship the volume
of the transportation by ship well you
know catan and then if we kind of did
hurting another another fire yeah but
does it yeah 10 a woman to sedate is a
union such a moment Thalia channel yeah
good new ones and Chris Harless sure to
endure your job dear oil in dollar each
ma so the Houston in Houston the low
sulfur content oil has come to one
thousand dollars fatah you do so rugo
gender pay me using shampoo yachts in
the valley who would turn decision
number how agent to hope of future day
so it means if they really implement the
regulation so the is a very big d dust
for the for the marine industry there's
a time of the survey to try new mega
tougher than face a penalty but for us
if the ship owners using the spar being
technology natural seawater scribing
technologies very low price and low cost
total food to digest rohana so Shingo
your hard apparently so it means the
only one percentage of the cost of the
using the lomo the oil just down the
track this is very big different it's a
huge difference it pays for the cost of
the system very quickly yes
cheap and every summer they have to go
out for two months for training and the
chief of the ER this should be going
there the Holy renegotiate the price of
oil and mean it finds the cheapest
that's where they're going so the when I
where you're going to go on a summer
until he finds the cheapest oil in
Guatemala wherever this is where they
going so yeah oh yes safe day when the
last Kayla doesn't have a huge
difference on the sulfur content in the
ocean but he said locally there could be
Emperor here a high concentration of
sulfur does that affect the marine life
in any way so very close to the ship
there may be an increase in the
concentration of sulfur because of the
waste seawater yes is there any study
about whether that would harm 0 y se la
a picture just begun anything so this
picture maybe you can make sense you can
actually huh they say all that high high
street the to vendo Josiah Darla five
minutes tempeh so we can see in the
content of the ocean the water in the
ocean the sulfate is occupied almost ten
point eight percentage point is I enjoy
a higher sem images are present may go
joey yung ho tung go Kwai Chang qu me
cutie levitation Cooney hey I am samudio
to rockland ave mohan transgender y yo
so as to the impact of this kind of
technology they see water squirming
technology the impact for the creatures
in the ocean the united states norway
united kingdom and China have a
long-term research and very long time
and
on scale monitoring number tell you to
the children just so what other do it
quite often is it your heart so we have
come to the same conclusion that
Professor danja has mentioned it's
friendly to the ocean that's what did
you say woman 2 G finish a minute okay
what did he do Julia Vietnam but she did
run to the control Joe changing go on da
way moda en y OU gentle so we also make
a lot of monitoring when we built the to
power power stations GT da ginger well
zhengzhou CEO john walker ya na hai hai
annual so it was supervised by the China
South say Research Institute ten Megaton
attended the Chan Ho Dovahkiin daremo de
pago trades bottom sin duda I am
somewhat gentle so there will be a lot a
very big scale of monitoring before and
after the construction of the power
station into the sea the creators pizza
diga the in town that changes the whole
yo-yo jungle closure yet tamiya jeans
unit tong dow bua end up today I'm going
to ensure the ginger so there's a about
the five at least five years continuous
monitoring super iced by the China
scientific Institute I'm a dongle change
our children yet immuno tell Tom Watson
said Ingo habeo so enjoyed unit so that
proved the conclusion dropped by the the
north Europe and the United Kingdom let
me add briefly there's a huge difference
between sea water and fresh water this
kind of you know stuff going into
freshwater would not be a good and so
this kind of technology would not be
appropriate for instance for the big
fire the coal-fired power plants you
wouldn't want to use lake water the type
of fresh like water for this oh but the
ocean is pretty mineral-rich already
right okay thank you adequacy so what is
the situation in regard to other
technologies who else has this kind of
sea water technology is anyone else
working on this message it had a hit
song who this is easy to five minutes
usually she's acknowledging Valentina
know whom to though the autos in the
toggle you'll see da da pata coming year
kappa can bother to the EGC as we know
there are was there is a 708 companies
in Europe to develop the EGC using in
lib there's a children top oven say that
those that cover just wanna sort of
heart Regina so most of them developing
the so-called chemical method to you
jack coming home yeah Jack have a
heightened so only one company as
seamless was didn't see what one very
unusual thing about your company mr.
pang is that you were early in adopting
a kind of what I would call a Western
approach to intellectual property and
taking out patents and I know that
you've actually had to with the the
onshore power had to defend your patents
and in court already can you say a
little bit about the patenting behind
this process that's what I'm just so
glad you think it's funny the winner
your gentleman holy Eric attorney that
Senator sound and tana by you too good
to good see chances without Johnny how
many women to have at hamburger to be
abolished thank you girly beautiful
woman three you're right jodiendo
diggity so Tina you can send ye capisci
three women give a woman she the good
guys in a puffin owe me a no good i sent
another 20 so as we developed the civil
for technology using in ship we update
the versions of the technology using
power station so we also applied
patterns in several countries you're
changing soldier some of the countries
also show related also rest of us you
home we are for them but yeah there is a
good code is in town it's a very
different from the power station because
it is the most international industry
yeah the most perfect every other player
Jenny do sir cadogan ojala change so
there's my friend is it because it gives
us a lot of advices on the pattern any
other questions if not I'd like to
suggest that we have some refreshments
outside and talk more informally first
please join me in thanking mr. ping
again for coming all the way
you